sitit ville d'importance moyenne au
sud-ouest de Leipzig Fisher c'est le nom
de cette famille de tiit que nous avons
regardé vivre une famille standard de
RDA oui et non une famille choisie pour
nous par les autorités alors une famille
modèle disons que les fishers lui contre
maître elle institutrice 35 ans deux
enfants sont une famille type de la
moyenne supérieure parmi les 17 millions
et demi d'habitants de la République
démocratique
allemande l'usine tmag exploitée
jusqu'en 1954 par les Soviétiques compte
aujourd'hui 3000 ouvriers elle se
consacre à la fabrication de grues et de
matériel lourds destiné aux usines de
transformation du
ligit il ne s'agit pas de n'importe
quelle usine au demeurant elle est
décorée de l'Ordre carlmx un modèle de
qualité d'ordre et de sécurité diton
ici une bonne proportion de ces enfants
fréquentera ensuite le centre de
formation Polytechnique qui à la source
fourn en cadre techniciens et ouvriers
supérieurs l'usine l'usine ce foyer
vital point de départ et d'arrivée de
l'activité
économique
le travail est organisé par brigade
début 7h ou 8h du matin fin de la
journée 16h ou 17h pause à midi 2 jours
de repos par semaine moyenne des
salaires 5 à 600 marques par
mois problème numéro 1 le plein emploi
est au maximum il va falloir faire appel
à la main d'œuvre de l'extérieur mais
toujours au nom de la solidarité
il ne s'agit pas de déshabiller Pierre
pour habiller Paul à recommander le 8e
congrès du Parti socialiste unifié le SD
le Parti communiste au
pouvoir l'objectif permanent est
d'améliorer la
productivité autant et plus stimulation
matériell on fera appel aux motivations
idéiques
le comité syndical d'entreprise dont
Monsieur Fisher a la
responsabilité donne chaque mois le
palmarè de la meilleure brigade avec le
nombre de
[Musique]
points
brile
34 l'émulation l'l de be non seulement
de la productivité à l'usine mais aussi
de toute la vie sociale en
RDA de maîre mot de notion clé
performance compétitivité
socialiste und wir müssenakch aufem
Gebiet noch
entschetsch tout est question
d'éducation et d'encadrement S meilleur
rien n'est laissé au hasard dès les bans
de l'école la RDA apprend à être cette
société attentive appliqué fier de ses
[Musique]
réussiteschte SAG jeoud dire ce
n je suis non seulement heureux de faire
mon
travail responsabilité syndicale je suis
aussi très heureux de pouvoir vivre dans
cet état de
RDA et d'être un membre à part entière
de notre
société à mon avis c'est quelque chose
d'important je gagne 100 marques par
mois
brut ce n'est pas ce que je rapporte
chaque mois à la
maison il y a encore làdessus les imp
f je rapporte la maison net 820 Mar par
Moisel les 550 marques mensuell de
Madame fer une organisation remarquable
sur le plan de l'enfance il y a une
pépinière de jardin
d'enfant ajouter des loyers très modérés
un bon F3 ou F4 pour 80 s marque vous
obtenz un niveau de vie tout à fait
correct
la gamme des produits de consommation
courante s'est élargi certes les prix
ont augmenté mais dans des proportions
tolérables alors alors on peut faire des
plans d'avenir la famille Fisher a
acheté un bout de terrain et plus tard
elle fera construire 5h3 de l'après-midi
monsieur fer est chez lui télévision ne
deutchland le journal du parti monsieur
fer a choisi il sait que la seule voie
du bien vivre est l'intég complète à la
société
[Musique]
socialiste